nouveau roi d'Angleterre.
- Il y a personne de mieux
préparé pour être roi, là...
- Né en 1948 au palais
de Buckingham, nommé
prince de Galles en 1969.
- C'est finalement à 73 ansôôôô.
DANIEL BÉLAND, dir. Institut
d'études canadiennes de McGill
- Sa vie ça se résume en partie
donc à cette attente, mais auss.
- Charles a étudié dans
les grandes écoles d'Angleterre
et a été pensionnaire en Écosse.
Diplômé
il a servi dans la Royal Air
Force etanans la marine.
- C'est quelqu'un qui est
cult
qui a beaucoup voyagé,
mais c'est pas quelqu'un qui
dé
et donc, ça c'est un peu
un problème pour la monarchie.
pompe Diana Spencer, Lady Di.
La relation qu'il aura avec
Ensemble, ils ont deux fils,
William et Harry.
plus tard. Charles admettra
une relation extra-conjuguale
son amour de jeunesse.
Lady Di meurt d'un accident
- La façon dont les médias ont
rapporté sa relation avec Diana,
à son image en général.
- À 56 ans, Charles épouse
celle qui deviendra bientôt
la reine consort.
d'architecture et d'écologie
le prince Charles est aussi
a créé sa propre fondati..
Les causes qu'il défend vontnes
à la protection d f forêts.
- Ses passions, ses intérêts,ent
pourraient jouer un rôle dans,
je dirais, son discours
en tant que monarque'i'i'i'i'i't
nnnner à son règne.
- Comme pr
il est venu de nombreuses fois
au Cana.a. Sa dernière visite
remonte à mai dernier.
- C'
très, très, terre à terre.
- omomas Morin-Cabana
l'a rencontré deux fois.
Société de la Couronne du Canada
- C'est une peononne qui aime
beaucoup rencontrer les gens
et parler aux gens.
d'initiative des Canadiens.
- C'esunun militaire montréalais
choisi par la reine qui l'a aidé
à p
à l'été de ses 11 ans.
-  y y a un attachement
particulier pour le Canada.
"Je retourne chez moi
auau Canada." Puis, je pense
que c'est un peu le sentiment
- Le prince de Galles
devra maintenant mieux
se faire connaître ici et dans
- Quand on est moins populaire
que donc, la personne qu'on
remplace, c'est toujours
cette personne-là,
c'est sa propre mère.
- Je pense pas qu'il attendait
tout ça. Au contraire, je pense
qu'il la redoutait, qu'il avait
peur de ce moment fatidique.
commence son règne. Il sera
proclamé Charles III vendredi
et sera couronné dans six mois.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier
Radio-Canada, Montréa